are you gonna sign it no because i want
you a bad number
all right sir like i explained to you uh
he can't be in the park at night
everyone's gonna receive a simple ticket
stating that uh he was in the park half
hour all right
right here
what am i signing over is it is it a
charge or anything it's or
a ticket
this one here
all right
copying yourself station you have any
questions
all right
come over here for me man
can you come here man
all right so you're gonna receive a
ticket for being in the park after hours
all right just need to shine right here
on the axe
but because we're out of do you say
we're out of time so we wouldn't have
known that
yeah but that's that's not about the
reason why
we should be in the park because you're
from london and what's your number seven
four five two
okay what's your name officer brooks
what's your first name i'm not
i'm not gonna give you my first name
and i don't have to sign this right you
do have to sign it no i don't okay
well like i explained to him if you
don't sign it then you're going to be
physically taken to jail got you
so you refusing to sign
what's your name
officer brooks7452
what's the best number i gave it to you
two times man okay i'm asking again and
i'm not giving it to you
are you gonna sign it no because i want
your bad number
hey listen man she said she's not
signing
put your hands behind your back
sorry
you're hurting me okay i'm actually
gonna put your hands behind your back
sir put your hands behind your back
put your hand behind your back
i need you to back up i'm just saying i
need you to back up you don't need to
touch her like that she's not putting
her hands behind her back i'm asking and
i'm asking a question
i'm just all i'm doing your hands behind
your back put your hands behind you
you're under arrest put your hands
behind your back i asked you to sign the
ticket you told me you're not signing it
sorry
i'm letting you know i'm not going to
ask you again i'm going to forcefully
put your hands behind your back but
sorry
mr brooks
is this really necessary
mr brooks hold on hold on hold on hey
listen let me see it's not good
i'm going to sign the ticket no i'm not
here to play games here i know but i'm
going to put your hands behind you mr
brook i'm going to tie your hands behind
your
i'm going to find the ticket i'm going
to sign the ticket
that's
i'm going to sign the ticket why am i
being arrested can you please tell me
why i'm being arrested oh my god
i'm so scared my god please in the name
of jesus please got my name why am i
being arrested mr brooks i'm going to
sign a ticket
mr front
why am i being arrested
why am i being arrested i don't
understand why i'm being arrested can
you please tell me why i'm being
arrested
turn around and put your hands down tell
me why i'm being arrested i have the
right
put your hands behind your back
come on sir this is unnecessary
what are you doing
just put your hands behind your back i
don't understand why i'm being arrested
that's why i'm not putting my hands
behind my back you have not given me a
reason
i'm not gonna be you they haven't told
me my right still told me why i've been
arrested that's why what about him
[Applause]
oh my god
[Music]
please
that's why i have not put my hands
behind my back you have not told me that
you have not read me my rights or
anything and you're steady doing this to
me i don't understand
can you please just tell me why i've
been arrested that's all i'm asking i
just told you why why refuse to sign the
truth
i told you i was gonna sign the ticket
mr brooks i told you i was gonna sign
the ticket can i please buy this ticket
put your hands behind your back
i don't understand put your hands behind
your back man how are you i'm gonna sign
the ticket mr brooks i will sign the
ticket please put your hands behind your
back i don't understand put your hands
behind your feet
put your hands behind your back
you are hurting me okay put your hands
behind me
you have not done any of that you're not
telling me why i'm going to jail
put your hands behind your back
come on man
oh my god
[Music]
oh
code 463
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god
that was unnecessary
[Music]
you can record from over here
[Applause]
my god
[Applause]
get in the car
oh
oh my god go ahead and search her before
i'll put
you sure
okay all right
oh my god
put your finish up
oh my god
can i have my phone
yeah i can give him your phone can you
please give him my phone that's fine
thank you
nick can you please get my
phone mr boyce is going to give you my
phone
no i told her
no i'm saying
but my gps kept going like that
because i thought
my neck and my neck
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
my god
have you given nick my phone yet
i'll give it to him when i'm ready
nick please call my parents nick please
my call is zero six one seven eight
seven eight when he gives you my phone
please call my mom it's called mommy and
my phone please call my mom or my sister
nick okay
oh my god
oh my god
mr brooks i'm in pain right now
i got gradient route
oh my god oh my god
i don't understand
i don't understand
i'm hurting i'm in pain right now
oh my god
please
please
please god please
in the name of jesus right now lord god
i pray that you help the support for god
i praise oh god that anything that is on
him right now any demon that is
possessing him
that you release it right now in the
name of jesus lord god
put your seatbelt on
thank
um
so
detention start minus three three
four three i'm turning really bad please
till we go to the hospital
we're in right to the hospital now
how long will it take
your breath
i'm not sure we're in route right now i
can't hear you we're enroute to the
hospital how long will it take to get to
the hospital
oh
please